EXIST.
>> Bret: THANK YOU.
>> ♪ ♪
>> Bret: IN TONIGHT'S WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO, ONE VIEWER ASKED
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE PAKISTANI
DOCTOR THAT HELPED CONFIRM THE
COMPOUND WHERE OSAMA BIN LADEN
WAS HIDING AND HE WAS LATER
IMPRISONED?
$33 MILLION IS BEING WITH HELD
FROM PAKISTAN UNTIL THAT
DOCTOR'S RELEASE.
CONNOR POWELL HAS THE STORY.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS
CONDUCTED AN OPERATION THAT
KILLED OSAMA BIN LADEN.
THE LEADER OF AL-QAEDA.
>> PRESIDENT OBAMA'S
ANNOUNCEMENT IN 2011 MARKED THE
END OF ONE OF AMERICA'S LARGEST
MANHUNTS IN HISTORY.
AMERICANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CELEBRATED OSAMA BIN LADEN
DEMISE.
THE RAID OF HIS COMPOUND
PRODUCED INFORMATION ABOUT
AL-QAEDA OPERATION.
IT WOULD NOT HAVE HAPPENED
WITHOUT THE HELP OF A PAKISTANI
PHYSICIAN.
>> HE WAS CRITICAL TO CAPTURE
AND KILL OSAMA BIN LADEN.
HE RAN A VACCINATION PROGRAM FOR
HEPATITIS THAT ALLOWED US TO
CONFIRM THE DNA OF TERRORISTS IN
THE AREA.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE BIN LADEN
FAMILY.
>> WHILE HE AND THE NAVY SEALS
WERE HAILED AS HEROES IN THE
U.S., BACK AT HOME, THE DOCTOR
IS NOT HAILED AS A HERO BUT AS A
TRAITOR.
FOLLOWING THE OSAMA BIN LADEN
RAID, AUTHORITIES ARRESTED THE
DOCTOR AND SENTENCED HIM TO 33
YEARS IN PRISON.
HIS CHARGE:
TREASON.
IN AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH
FOX NEWS IN 2012, THE DOCTOR
TOLD US HE WAS TORTURED.
THE DOCTOR DESCRIBED HOW HE HAD
BEEN BURNED WITH CIGARETTES AND
SHOCKED WITH ELECTRICITY WHILE
OFFICERS CURSED AMERICA.
DONALD TRUMP VOWED TO SUGGEST
THE DOCTOR'S RELEASE.
TELLING FOX NEWS IN APRIL OF
2016, HE COULD GET IT DONE IN 2
MINUTES.
>> LET HIM OUT.
I AM SURE THEY WOULD LET HIM
OUT.
WE GIVE A LOT OF MONEY TO
PAKISTAN.
>> THE GOVERNMENT CUT FINANCIAL
AID TO PAKISTAN.
SO FAR PAKISTANI LEADERS HAVE
REFUSED PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
REQUESTS TO RELEASE THE DOCTOR